we talked earlier in the program about
how the Cowboys would like to deal
directly with players that's one of the
reasons why agent Rafi Arceneaux has his
EQ Elliott a in Cabo and not with the
team in Dallas but Chris regardless of
who the Cowboys are talking to Jerry
Jones the Cowboys owner said on
Wednesday that they are not making any
progress not any movement at all and
there were no talks planned in the next
day or so and we're getting closer and
closer to week one I think both sides
are really dug in I agree this hold out
the last into the regular season yeah
I'm with you Mike all the way they're
just that doesn't look like I had some
people like texting me you know about
their fantasy league should I drop Zika
Elliott you think he's gonna come back
soon and I just said you know I don't
know I have no inside info here but it
just doesn't look good I don't expect it
to happen
I really don't and you know again I just
I look at it I still think this week one
matchup for the Dallas Cowboys is gonna
be dangerous I think the Giants can
match up with the Cowboys in a lot of
different ways I know they're not
necessarily as talented but they are big
up front the New York Giants and Pat
Shermer dick Gettleman what they've
build with their offensive line and
their front seven on defense I think
does give the Cowboys some issues and
I'm I mean Mike what do you think it is
I mean it's simple as this Mike he's
being offered something between Le'Veon
Bell and Todd Gurley and he wants more
than Todd Gurley right I mean that's
what it seems like yes and also the
Cowboys spent months thinking that they
would be able to kick this into next
year they didn't have their brains
wrapped around the reality that they
were gonna have to pay as EQ Elliott now
they thought they could focus on
quarterback dak Prescott receiver Amari
Cooper next year deal with the see
especially you know hey we saw what
happened to talk early in year four and
the Rams surely wish in hindsight they
hadn't given Todd Gurley his contract
after only three seasons so they had the
protection that came from that another
year of wear and tear where is Zeke at
that point how much do we really really
want to pay him and also how much does
the offense change under Kellen Moore
maybe seats no longer the focal point
after a see out of dak Prescott and
Amari Cooper a bay horse off
so maybe that's a way you can squeeze
Zeke next year I just think all the
factors combined they weren't ready for
this and now they don't know how to get
out of this mess without making easy qle
at the highest paid running back in the
NFL and they don't want to do it know
well they need to do it because that's
what he deserves and that's what he is
and you know unlike Todd Gurley and I
know they can look at that and go oh wow
you know he got he got his money and
then he got hurt yeah but he has no
injury history I mean the guy is a
sledgehammer I mean he just built to
withstand that it looks like it I mean I
don't know you know you look at a mic I
mean look how dense he is I mean it
looks like if you tried to stick a knife
into his shoulder the knife would Bend
it wouldn't go in I mean that's just
this how powerful of a human being he is
and I don't think he's a guy that is
gonna get injured or fall off Earth here
anytime soon he was put on earth to play
running back in the NFL with the way
he's built and he has never shown any
signs of being hurt or anything like
that and Gurley as we know came into the
NFL hurt and and with some issues there
so it is a different scenario and you
know I think ultimately as eeks doing
the right thing and I hope he does get
get to be the highest-paid running back
in the sport and I think Jerry Jones is
trying to lay the foundation to declare
victory when Elliott returns around week
six or week seven as he will need to do
in order to get credit for this year of
his contract there was an arbitration
that was filed by Joey Galloway years
ago I remember the end result of that is
you need to be on the active roster if
you're under contract you need to be on
the active roster for at least eight
games to get credit for this year of
your contract otherwise everything gets
kicked back by another year and Zeke has
gained nothing so I could see him
showing up around week six a week seven
and consider this quote from Jerry Jones
on Wednesday to 105 3 the fan in Dallas
we've got a marathon here when we get to
the playoffs
we want Zeke we want Zeke when we're in
the dog days of the season that means
when Zeke shows up week six week seven
week eight and he gets there in time
to be on the active roster for eight
games Jerry can say hey this is all we
wanted anyway who cares about the first
six games yeah we want him to be ready
to go for the important games so they're
already staking out that territory to be
able to say it's fine miss a you missed
five or six regular season that's fine
we didn't need you for those games
anyway we need you for the important
games so we still got our way well then
the Zeke needs us to put a statement out
there and goes you know when I get there
a week six and seven and I'm a little
tired in the third and fourth quarter
I'm coming out of the game sorry I'm
just tired I'm just I don't know if I'm
in good enough shape yet I mean he's got
to do things to protect his life and his
body then if they want to play hardball
that way you know I always go back to
this it's hard to be a player like
Ezekiel Elliott when you know you're
getting very close to becoming getting
into a situation where you go ooh I my
life is going to change forever I'm
gonna be able to support my family
forever you've heard me tell the story
about Brandon Marshall right I mean I'm
there in the Eagles locker room we're
getting ready to play them he's about to
be a big time you know a free agent wide
receiver and it's week 16 he's got he's
yelling I can't play like this I can't
it's just me and him in the locker room
but he's letting me know he can't go out
there and just be the Beast Brandon
Marshall wants to be because he knows
he's two games away from you know
changing his whole life and and
everything he worked hard for and that's
where I hope the fans gonna have some
sympathy for the player in these type of
situations we always know about the
holdout the hold in is a very real
dynamic the NFL where a guys maybe got a
hamstring issue maybe he's got some
headaches yeah got some back problem
right until he gets that new contract
and that's something we can't run out
that not that we condone it yeah not
that we condone the the the shenanigans
are but we do happen from time to time
you need to be ready for that
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports